you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food ultimate
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas i've loved it ever since i was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
i've given it a few modern tweaks
for my ultimate fish i'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of ginger
to go with it chilly minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that will keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic now the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour i want a bit of heat in the batter
so
a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then
two teaspoons of baking powder
this
almost lightens the load with the batter
now ginger beer
it gives that batter this sort of unique
spicy individual flavor it's delicious
with a fish and a nice tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
sheen
give it a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of double cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture
let it rest for as long as possible to
give you an even textured batter
now the season should have worked its
magic and drawn out the excess moisture
from the fish so it's on to the next
stage
fish
has gone slightly firmer
perfect for frying
start by coating the fish in flour
seasoned with pepper
pat that nice and dry into your hands so
you haven't got any excess flour the
flour stops the batter from running off
the fish i'm just gonna check to see if
my oil's ready by putting a little touch
of batter
into the fryer
you see it bubbling straight to the very
top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan above halfway if the oil
starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist
your pan
that stops it from sticking
at the bottom
oil should be gently sort of bubbling
away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no
spitting of any water from the fish fry
the fish for three to five minutes
gently turning halfway through
once the batter is golden and crisp it's
ready
look they look stunning it's like these
big crispy pillows of beautifully
textured cotton
leave the fish to rest on a kitchen
towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chilli
minted mushy peas
now how much you peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
and a nice
knob of butter
into the pan
shallot
finely chopped that adds a bit of
sweetness to the peas slots into the pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy
they're even better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chilli the
garlic and the schlotz
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch and salted boiling water infuse
with their perfect partner
fresh mint stalks and all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the peas i've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
i love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there
a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed
delicious peas look at that
those peas is incredible
top with chopped mint
chilli minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish a nice spicy crispy batter and that
just
reaffirms
the importance of comfort food if you're
gonna do it
do it properly
[Music]
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic
and the best way to eat this is with
crispy buttered sauteed potatoes cooked
with garlic rosemary and thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
when i was growing up food in britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you could
even buy avocados in the shops where i
lived paris kitchens might have been
cooking nouvelle cuisine but it
certainly hadn't made any inroads around
our way moulton at lunch when i was
growing up was very plain
pretty trashy but i still love it now
and again fish fingers with a delicious
chip butty
the secret
of a good chip butti
is in the potato
now these are desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today i'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist
simply peel
slice and blanch for three to four
minutes
drain
season
and cover well with propeca
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that
next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock
a really nice firm delicious
fish
got the fish in finger size batons of
fish put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish
it firms the fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour
and then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then it stops those corners
almost burning in the pan
in to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful
and then this is dill
goes brilliantly well with a fish
and run the dill through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
and a nice
little knob of
butter
that'll work wonders with the
breadcrumbs and the dill
nice and carefully
take them out
and look and smell incredible
so nice and crispy
now to assemble my chip butty starting
with butter thick crusty bread
[Music]
slice of bread
mop up that amazing flavor
on
slice in half
never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship buddy there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food but
my god that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for one moment when
want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
boiled eggs with a soldier that will
make your taste buds stand to attention
there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magic when you slice that top
off and dunk that soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what i like to dunk in
it an anchovy soldier anchovies
interpersonal water no salt naturally
yeah anchovies are very salty so just a
touch of pepper
in omega-3s the amazing tinned anchovy
is a natural flavor enhancer and i use
it to pepper many a savory dish from
roast lamb to the humble toasted soldier
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being at
the seaside now get your soft butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 percent anchovy 50
butter that way got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish i'm in heaven
the bread
this is a sourdough
delicious very crusty
take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell of the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil
the secret of softly boiling an egg is
to place them into the water gently on a
spoon
in
and just tilt so they don't hit the
bottom nice
and light
up to the boil count to five turn the
gas down
is it four and a half minutes is it five
minutes for a softball day i've cooked
thousands of them and every time
it's four and a half minutes whilst
that's boiling
get your bread
and spread that on there that is
incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
inside but i can't resist
oh my god
right
gas off
one
beauty in
two
i feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
you